[MUSIC PLAYING]
THOMAS STEINER:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
My name is Thomas Steiner.
I'm based out of the
Hamburg, Germany office.
And I work on mobile web stuff,
m mostly with big partners.
And with me today is my
guest speaker, Steven.
Steven, do you want to come
up and introduce yourself?
STEVEN SONEFF:
Hi, so I'm Steven.
I'm a product manager
at Google in California.
And I'm just visiting, guest
speaking today on the topic
of identity and authentication
on the mobile web.
THOMAS STEINER: Thank you.
So today, we want
to show you what's
next for the web, or as
an alternative title,
exploring about flags.
But before we get started,
here's a fair warning.
There's a lot of content coming.
And I'm going to speak fast,
probably even too fast.
So hold onto your seats.
And especially, watch
out for all the links.
So many of the
slides have links.
And of course, you can just
snap a photo of the slide,
so you can look up some of the
content after the presentation.
So let's get going.
Let's get started.
Our first big topic area
is Progressive Web Apps,
or short PWAs.
Let me show you how you
can, with PWAs, create
immersive, full-screen
experiences.
Because your apps deserve a
lot of screen real estate.
So some of you may remember
from I/O 2016, the Paper Planes
World app.
It's actually still up
at paperplanes.world.
If you go online, you
can test this app.
If you launch this application,
you might notice something.
This is a web app.
But if you look at
the screen at the top,
there is no network signal,
no clock, no battery status
indication.
It's a true fully immersive,
full-screen experience.
And it can do this by
setting the display
property in your web app
manifest to the value
of full screen--
pretty new, very exciting
for game developers.
And yeah, hopefully, you try
it out for your application.
For PWAs, we also
have an improved add
to homescreen experience.
Many users install
the PWA, they will not
be able to find PWAs in
the Android app drawer,
just within all your
other native applications.
So they look, and
behave, and finally,
react as true
native applications.
So you can just
search for your app,
find it in your app drawer.
And there's something
that a lot of developers
have really been
looking forward to.
You can now also update the icon
and change the application name
after your application
is installed.
And something that's
really cool as well
is, with the improved
flow, you can now,
based on the scope
attribute that [INAUDIBLE]
in the Web App Manifest, create
an Android intent filter that
allows you to react
whenever your URL pattern
within the scope is hit.
So your application can just
open directly whenever it is
being mentioned-- somewhere
in a chat, for example--
and then directly go
into the PWA experience.
The next thing is
the Web Share API.
Because we all do know
that sharing is caring.
And if you want to do that on
pretty much any site in 2017,
you end up with an
experience like the one
that you can see on this slide.
So a lot of screen real
estate is, in a sense,
wasted for all these
sharing buttons.
And of course, looking at the
sharing buttons, all this,
the one social network that you
actually would want to share on
is not on the list.
And as we have seen
in the previous slide
with the full-screen
experience, sometimes
also just the URL bar is hidden.
So you need a different way
of sharing your application.
And this brings me
to the Web Share API.
It's directly integrated with
the native Android sharing
dialog, which is really cool.
Because there, you have
a truly native experience
of sharing your content.
So if you look at
this code snippet,
it's very short,
navigator.share.
And then it can give a title.
You can give a text.
And you can give a URL.
And this allows it to
change the URL that
is displayed on the screen.
So for example, when
you think of something
that is hosted somewhere
or embedded in an AppCache,
for example.
The next topic is
push notifications.
And actually, the next thing
is most interesting or only
interesting for macOS users.
Because finally, on
macOS, the notifications
are integrated directly in
the native system Notification
Center.
So they'll no longer
feel like strangers.
They're now just
native notifications,
which also means they respect
your devices or your system's
do not disturb setting,
which is super,
super powerful, of course.
Because you don't
want to be disturbed
by notifications when you give
a presentation, for example.
So now, finally,
this is possible.
So the next topic is kind
of an interesting topic.
Some companies ship down
3 megabytes of image data
and then shrink it down
on the client side.
And other companies have
worries about performance
of the service worker,
so service work boot
time being too long.
So this is pretty
exciting new API--
or it's an origin
trial, actually--
navigation preload.
What this does is
it kind of makes
the time where the
service worker boots up
not waiting time, but parallel
time that your app can already
use for a navigation request.
So if you look at
this little diagram
here down at the
bottom of the slide,
you can see the service
of the boot time before
and the service of the boot time
after this trial is activated.
So you can see, it's
running in parallel.
So the request can
already happen.
So how do you use that?
If you look at this code, you
can see, there's two events--
the activate event
and the fetch event.
In the activate event, with
his highlighted yellow line,
waitselfregistra
tionnavigationpreload.enable,
you enable navigation preload.
And then in your fetch
listener, after going
through the chain of, do I
have the cached response,
no or yes, you can then
check if maybe there
is a preloaded response
available that you can then
directly ship to the user.
So this allows you to get
content to the user faster
without waiting time for
the service worker to boot.
On mobile, you now have a pretty
exciting new way of signing up.
And for this, let me
bring Steven on stage.
STEVEN SONEFF: OK,
thanks, Thomas.
So what we'll talk
about here is one part
of the experience of
building a mobile web
app that is often frustrating.
And it's only a small part.
But it's often a big problem
that developers encounter.
And it's how to get people
signed in and signed up
on such a small screen.
You've probably
all had experiences
that looked like
this before, where
you have to remember a
username, password, type it
in on a mobile keyboard.
And perhaps, you've
added something
like Google Sign-In or
Facebook Login to your app.
But there are people using it.
There's always been
a concern about what
data gets shared, how these
work on a mobile browser,
and how you'll end
up back on the site.
So what my team has been
thinking about at Google
is ways to improve
this experience
for the mobile browsers
that are out there.
And what we are
working on right now
is a new and unreleased API.
It adds an I-frame
to your mobile site,
where you can offer a one-tap
sign up or sign in experience.
This gets someone
in to your site
or signed up through
checkout or conversion flows
with as little
friction as possible.
And as a new thing, we'd
love to hear the feedback
from developers like you on how
this might fit into your site.
So check out the link
or send me an email.
Stick around for questions
after to discuss more.
And send us feedback on this
part of the mobile experience.
Thank you.
THOMAS STEINER: So
how can you use that?
Essentially, there's two
API calls that you can make.
For auto sign in, you can
use smartlog.retrieve.
And for auto sign up, you
can use a smartlog.hint
with a couple of
configuration things.
So as I said,
you're not supposed
to understand this code
in this short time.
This is just for you to
get an idea about what
will be possible pretty soon.
So let's get back
to PWAs in general.
A question that we get a lot
when people develop a PWA
and we talk about cache as well,
what even am I allowed to use?
Like, how much
storage do I have?
Or if they already have a cache
and it's full with content
or somewhat full with content,
they're wondering about,
how much of my cache I'm
actually already using?
So with the new
Storage Estimation API,
you can now find out.
So you just very easily call
navigator.storage.estimate.
And then when the
promise fulfills,
you get data about how much
storage you're already using
and how much storage
is available in total.
So super useful feature,
a long time thing that was
awaited very, very eagerly
by developers of PWA.
So let's move on to the
next big topic area, which
is media-related APIs.
Media on the web
is very exciting.
And the first API that
I want to talk about
is the Image Capture
API, because you should
be zooming in on what matters.
So on the screenshot, you can
see what matters is my face.
So I'm zooming in on my face
in this stupid animation
that I created for this slide.
So this API allows you to
actually natively zoom in.
And so this is not
software-enlarged.
This is a native
zoom of the camera.
And you can use this
directly from your browser.
And this is how you do it.
So for this little demo
here, you can see the slider.
And the slider does need to
know, of course, how much
can it slide?
So what is the maximum
zoom level, essentially?
And you can see in this
short snippet of code
how, from a media
stream, I first
get the video track, the first
one, check its capabilities.
And from the track, I check
the available settings.
And then I can use that
to update and create
my user interface like this.
I'll use it to zoom in with
the capabilities of the device
directly being used
and being applied.
So that's pretty
cool, pretty exciting.
Something even cooler
and even more exciting
is the Shape Detection
API that allows
you to detect faces,
read barcodes,
and even to run Optical
Character Recognition, OCR,
right in the browser.
You can see this
little demo here.
I was just holding
that phone and pointing
to different
browser tabs where I
had open, first, a
QR code, and then
on a second tab, a face
and some text here.
So you can see
how, in real time,
the API detects the different
objects on this page.
So this is directly
integrated in the browser.
So let me quickly
show you how it works.
You first need to initialize
the different detectors, so
the face detector,
the text detector
and the barcode detector.
And then you can just
listen for events.
So everything is promise-based.
So you can queue up all
the different promises,
facedetector.detect,
textdetector.detect, and so on.
And then you will get
the detected object
in the results--
so pretty cool,
super easy to use.
If you check out
this demo, you will
see it's 100 lines of
code and everything
directly working and
running in the browser, so
super exciting, super cool API.
I think this unlocks a lot
of cool new applications.
The next thing is the
Media Session API.
When you're playing
media content on the web,
you want to know, of course,
well, what is playing?
When is it playing?
And on a mobile device, you,
of course, want to control.
You want to skip forward,
go to the next track, pause.
This is all possible now
with the Media Session API.
You can see meta information
of the currently playing media.
And you can, of course,
directly control it.
So let me show you how this
works, and first, what kind
of metadata you can control.
So in the screenshot here,
you can see there's a title.
There's an artist.
There's an album.
There's artwork.
And then you have two
different action handlers
that you can set, so seek
backward, previous track,
and so on.
So a lot of things possible.
This block of code might first
look pretty intimidating.
But actually, it's
just two big things.
On the first half,
I'm just setting
here all the different media
metadata in the object.
And then at the
second half, I'm just
connecting the different
action handlers
and connecting functions
to the different events.
So super easy to use.
Again, very powerful,
great integration
in the native operating system.
WebVR, big topic,
super cool thing,
because sometimes the
real reality actually
is not real enough.
So WebVR allows you to create
compelling VR experiences
right in the browser.
It's an open standard
that, yeah, just allows
you to directly program
these kind of experiences,
so that everyone can get
VR experiences very easily.
On this demo created by
Martin [? Split, ?] you
can see how this
could change the lives
for interior designers,
for example, who could just
pass on a link to
the work that they've
created to their clients.
They don't have to install
any native 3D viewer software
or anything.
They can just take
out their VR goggles,
cardboards, whatever, and
just have a quick look at how
their future home might look--
super cool, directly
in the browser.
Performance, this is super
important, of course.
We preach performance a lot.
Performance-Related
APIs no longer
allow you to have an excuse for
having a bad-performing site.
Network Information
API is something
that you can use to know
how fast you can go.
Let me show you what
you can do here.
So based on the connection
type of the user,
you can now adopt
your experience.
So for example, you could show
someone low-resolution image
assets when they are
on a slow connection.
And you can, of course, also be
on mobile in a true mobile way.
So sometimes,
you're in a tunnel.
Sometimes you are--
I don't know-- somewhere
in the countryside.
And then sometimes, you
are just in the city.
So what I'm getting at
is connections change.
So of, course, you
don't want to have
someone with a
low-res experience
for the entire session.
But sometimes, when they
have a good connection,
you, of course, want to
give them high-res images.
And you can see in this code
how you can, first of all,
just read out the information,
but then, of course,
be notified when the
connection changes.
Why is this important?
Well, you, of course,
have media queries.
So you could say, well, this
user is on a retina display
super high-resolution capable.
But actually, combined
with network information,
it might, after all, not
make sense to show them
super high-resolution images.
So this is just a
short example how
you can programmatically from
JavaScript query media queries,
check for the result, and then
combine it with the Connection
API to see, well, is
the connection actually
right now good enough for
supporting high-res images?
So you can directly
work with media queries
and with the Connection
API together.
Then there is the
Core Performance API.
Because you do care--
or should be caring--
what's happening
when a page loads.
For this, I was very quickly
auditing the actual event
page for the GDD.
So there's a lot
of different things
that you can get and
calculate dynamically.
So you can see here, I'm
getting the perf data
from the
window.performance.timing
object.
And then you can calculate
a number of things, like,
for example, the page load
time, or the connect time,
or the render time.
And these are core metrics
that you could then just
simply report back to
your analytics back.
And I guess you could
see how the real users
in the real world out
there experience my page.
And if then see
alarming numbers,
then it's probably a
good idea to get going,
and improve your site,
and make it load faster
or render faster.
So that's really cool.
But then, this is only
one part of the story.
Something more interesting
and more important,
actually, is making sure that
content in a meaningful way
gets to the user.
So what it can do now is,
with the Paint Timing API,
information about
key painting events--
so when did what content
arrive at the user's device?
And there's even a
performance observer,
so you can get
dynamically notified
and react whenever a
certain paint event happens.
So I was auditing this page on
a simulated slow 3G connection.
And you can see here
in the console--
it's relatively small, I
think, but you can still
maybe see it--
the first paint and the
first contentful paint.
So when was the first
moment where something,
no matter what, was painted?
And when was the first moment
where something meaningful
was painted?
So for example,
text, for example,
an image, so that
people can actually
consume content and not just
stare at a gray background
or a white background--
so super useful API.
And of course, this
is a core metrics
that you can then, again,
report back to your analytics
and see if everything is OK.
Clients Hints, also
a very exciting topic
that allows you to adopt
and see what kind of device
you have to do with.
We have in Chrome
telemetry, so we kind of
get a feeling of what's
going on with the browser.
And we've noticed that a lot
of foreground tab crashes
are actually due to
out-of-memory exception.
So when the device
runs out of memory,
the Chrome tab might crash.
So you can see here
an Android phone
more on the cheap
end of the spectrum.
So for these kind of devices,
it might be a good idea
to maybe not serve
super, super high-res,
super RAM-heavy experiences.
But many adopt it.
So how can that work?
First of all, the
service can advertise
that they support Client Hints.
For this, there's a new HTTP
header called accept-ch, so CH
for Client Hints.
And then it can provide a list
of the different client hints
that your server
actually supports,
in this case, device memory.
And clients can then--
so user agents-- can then
send the device memory, for
example, and say, by the way,
I'm a poorish device.
I have 0.5 gigs of RAM only.
So that then the server
can adopt the experience
accordingly.
And also, you can read
all this information
on the client side
with JavaScript.
So you can just have a look
at navigator.devicememory
and see, what is the actual
hardware device memory
right now?
And you can also see, how
many cores does the CPU have?
So when you kind
of program a game,
for example, you
can decide, should I
use the heavy textures, or sure
I use the lighter textures--
dependent on device memory and
or the hardware concurrency.
So how many cores
does the CPU have--
super exciting,
great, new features.
Which then brings us to
Hardware-Related APIs.
The first API that
I want to mention
is the Web Bluetooth API,
which allows you to communicate
with nearby Bluetooth devices.
In this demo here, created
by Francois Beaufort,
you can see how,
with his phone, he's
controlling Bluetooth candles.
I wasn't sure that this
kind of thing exists.
But actually, it does exist--
Bluetooth candles.
And can see here why
this could be fun.
You can just allow
anyone with a device
that is in range to control
the experience here.
It's using the GAT, so
Generic Attribute Profile,
and uses Bluetooth 4, so
very energy-efficient.
It's partially implemented
in Chrome and Android, Linux,
macOS, and in Chrome OS--
very exciting API.
The next thing as well is
WebUSB, which allows you, well,
as the name suggests, to
expose USB devices directly
to websites.
This is, of course, not for
any and all USB devices,
but for USB devices that were
specifically designed for that.
In this demo here created
by Kenneth [? Rhodes ?]
Christiansen you
can see how he's
using WebUSB to talk
to an arduino board
to then display text
on a dot matrix screen.
So these devices need to
be specifically designed
for being used on the web.
And it's obviously HTTPS only.
So this is a very powerful API.
So we want to be sure
that this is HTTPS only.
And of course, it has
to be user-initiated.
So you can't just
silently, secretly
connect to a USB device.
It's always after
a user gesture.
Again, implemented in Chrome,
on Android, Linux, macOS,
and in Chrome OS.
And today, there
is one more thing.
Today, we are launching
WebSCSI, which
allows you to revive
your old SCSI hard disks,
bringing the '80s
back to the web.
SCSI is a Small Computer
System Interface,
a set of standards
for transferring
data between computers
and peripheral devices.
WebSCSI emulates a SCSI
controller right in the browser
and defines
interfaces for access.
It's landed in Chromium 64
Technology Preview Canary
Nightly--
very excited about that
This was, of course, a joke.
But what I was getting
at, this is not the end.
This is just the beginning.
The web is so great.
The web is ever-evolving.
And if you want to
stay up-to-date,
we very much invite you to
subscribe to developers.googl
e.com/web/updates and be
notified of all the new,
great things that are coming.
With that, [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH],,
Thomas Steiner and Stephen
Soneff.
[MUSIC PLAYING]